you have seven grammy nominations and  your parents when you were little used  to take you and you'd stand outside the  staples center  oh my gosh i've like dreamed about the  grammy since i was a little girl i've  just been a fan of it forever and so  it's just gonna be so exciting to go  there in the flash billy eilish she said  something about kind of she wanted to  keep you in a glass box and protect you  miss rodrigo who's been killing it i  just want to like shove her in a glass  box and like protect her from everything  i just think she's incredible it's so  cool to be able to look up to someone  like her i just really admire how  confident she is and how she just like  marches to the beat of her own drum and  i think she's incredible